for me i just really think that you know
the energy that you put out into the
world is going
to draw back the results that you you
know want to see or don't want to see
so as long as your energy is right then
you're going to be able to accomplish
whatever it is you're setting out to
accomplish you know what i mean
that's what i appreciate about your game
is you understand the art
of the independent hustle and creating
your own success
and now with the internet and everything
comedians can do that more than ever
right so like what are some ways or tips
you have for comics who
who should um or who could just build
their own foundation
well it's easier now than it's ever been
because you know
20 years ago if this was
you know my reality i would be all of us
really especially the people on while
and out
just to use that as an example would be
a whole lot more famous
if the internet didn't exist because if
the internet didn't exist the
access to us would be a whole lot less
you know than it is now so you think
when a living color was on like they
were superstars because the odds of you
being able to have
contact or interact with them or let
them know how you feel about them
whether it be negative or positive
was very difficult you had to write a
letter and then get a letter back
and then write another letter and then
you know what i mean like
it's different now now you have direct
access to anybody beyonce is the
biggest star in the world but you can go
on her instagram page and type a comment
in her comments
and the odds of her seeing that are a
whole lot
more than the odds of her saying the
letter 20 years ago in a
15 000 letters a day so just utilize
that
aspect and whatever it is you want to do
i don't care what it is if you want to
be a comedian if you just want to be an
instagram entertainer start
that's the biggest thing most people
just sit around and don't
start you can talk a hole in your head
but until you start putting forth the
effort
the universe ain't going to give you
nothing back because you haven't given
it anything to work off so you got to
put forth some type of effort just i
tell people that all the time
people come up and be like i want to be
a comic well have you done any stand-up
i don't care what you do especially
college students we do a lot of colleges
and
they were like man i want to be a
comedian i'm like man you're in college
they
have to utilize funds to let you do what
you want to do
do it while it's free because once you
leave here nothing's free anymore
everything costs money so the best thing
you can do while you're here
is utilize this place who is
put here to help advance you as a human
being
and do it for nothing when it doesn't
cost you anything and you learn the game
so when you get out here
and have to use your money you've
already built some type of
foundation if you have a skill set at it
that's going to follow you
and it makes it a little bit easier for
you to get out here and start to press
and push your envelope because you've
already started in a place where it
didn't cost you anything and
that pressure financial stability wasn't
on you you don't have that when you're a
college student
and for those people who aren't and just
trying to do it on their own
you can go to write aid and buy a cell
phone you know what i mean and you can
go to starbucks and get wi-fi
so it's really no excuse now for you not
to be able to put forth some type of
effort you you can't cheat the game
you have to put in the work you have to
get out here and put your feet on the
pavement
and do something and once you start
doing something
then you'll start to see the results of
you doing something and
you got to be able to recognize
what success is because even if you
you know go from i remember the first
instagram post i put up got 12 likes
you know i mean and i was excited about
the fact that i got 12. didn't show all
the names anymore
the number you know i mean but that's
the difference
that was the first 12 and i was excited
about that first 12 and i embraced that
first 12
to get to the next which was
24 and then you know 36
and then on and on and on but the only
way that happened is
putting the effort forth and embracing
the moment that you are in
like the walk is the walk you got to
embrace the ugly carlos me and carlos
say that all the time you got to embrace
the ugly
like rest in peace and nipsey hustle he
had a quote and said hey sometimes you
just gotta
cut out all the fun cut out all the
[ __ ]
get ugly and grind you know what i mean
that's the reality of what you have to
do those days when i was
how i got 332 000 miles on the saturn
view
is because i was out here in it
moving around every day
doing something working a regular job
and doing this
for no money just to get
myself in a situation where my energy is
starting to match
what i need to come back to me because
i'm putting forth the type of effort
that people are going to see even if you
don't like what i do
if you're watching i'm gathering all of
that and it's helping propel me to the
next step
and the only thing that getting to the
next level in anything that you do
it just gives you a better view of what
you can get to
you know i mean it's like if you can't
see over the edge when you finally get
up over the edge then you see everything
that's over the edge
so the more you climb and grow
it never stops you know i mean in the
things that you chase never stop jay-z
just became a billionaire
but he's still working bill gates and
all these different people and
you know i don't even everybody
that's successful they still work
because it's not about the money
it's about the view it's about what you
get to see
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips